Michael Oher has never been shy about
all the ways The Blind Side exaggerated
if not outright fabricated elements of
his life his career and his relationship
to the Tui family but things took an
even more shocking turn in August 2023
when it was revealed that Orr filed a
lawsuit claiming among other things that
Sean and Leanne Tui never adopted him
like the movie depicted in the lawsuit
Orr says that the tuis instead
manipulated him into giving them power
of conservatorship over him just after
he turned 18 which put them in the
position to control his business deals
because he was led to believe it would
make him a legal member of the Tui
family there are wonderful kids all over
this country in this world that want a
forever family and we believe that there
are no unwanted kids they're just
unfound families he seeks to end the
conservatorship and to force the tuis to
disclose all of the money they have
earned by using his name and license as
well as borrowing them from doing so in
the future